accedido a la justicia el comité
legislativo que Investiga el asalto del
6 de enero del 2021 al Capitolio
recomendó el departamento de Justicia
estadounidense imputar el expresidente
Donald Trump por obstrucción a la
justicia incitación al terrorismo
conspiración en contra del gobierno
federal y declaraciones falsas a la
justicia
La fe es la base de la Democracia
estadounidense si se rompe la fe se
rompe nuestra democracia y Donald Trump
la rompió perdió las elecciones de 2020
y lo sabía buscaba anular los resultados
con la intervención de varias partes
para bloquear la transferencia de poder
tras un año y medio de investigaciones
la comisión considera que Trump no actúa
en solitario además de encontrar que
pasó la tarde bien del ataque por
televisión el 6 de enero de 2021 unas
10.000 personas se manifestaron en
frente del Capitolio y cerca de 800
irrumpieron en el edificio mientras se
ratificaba la victoria del demócrata Joe
biden en las elecciones presidenciales
hubo cinco muertos y unos 140 heridos
fue la primera vez que un presidente
estadounidense rechazó su deber
constitucional de transferir el poder
pacíficamente al siguiente Durante los
últimos 18 meses el comité selecto ha
reconocido nuestra obligación de hacer
todo lo posible para garantizar que esto
nunca suceda otra vez
esta fue la última audiencia del 2022 en
la cual el comité quiso difundir sus
conclusiones antes de la nueva
legislatura el 3 de enero la mayoría
republicana que abre a partir de ese día
podría disolver este órgano y el
enjuiciamiento sería detenido